[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the house of rate steppers
are in full force this morning
their very first Witness
Jonathan Turley which I don't even know
why this guy still appears in Congress
but this morning he's like oh yeah hey
by the way
there's not a piece of evidence yet
not a piece of evidence
that suggests Joe Biden should be ain't
that about a [__] ain't that about a
[__] there's no evidence and just
before I came on
Daniel Goldman tried to introduce
evidence into the hearing and James q
and on Comer just wouldn't introduce
this evidence into the hearing it's very
telling about how many rakes these
[__] idiots have thrown out in front
of themselves over the last six months
now
also Jamie Raskin is absolutely
destroying House Republicans
not just with his words but with
procedure and it is very obvious that
they have put the clowns in charge
on the Republican side to defend Donald
Trump
they can't even they can't even they
can't
even run a goddamn Committee hearing let
alone keep the government open why they
took him 15 times to decide that Kevin
McCarthy was the best option that they
had to capitulate to Trump
when they were selecting a speaker
we have unserious people doing very
unserious things in our government our
government it's [__] hours not theirs
and it's about time the American people
[__] wake up to this nonsense this
[__] these [__] lies
it's all [__] lies in theater for
these idiots to protect their power
period
like last night the theater
that Donald Trump put on oh my God this
is hilarious a lot of people are really
[__] pissed off about this I'm
excited about this Donald Trump went to
a non-union plant paid people to hold
Union signs to pretend that he went and
talked to UAW members because UAW
members don't want to talk to that
[__] and the reason why is the
clip I played yesterday because they
know in their heart of hearts Donald
Trump doesn't give a [__] about the
worker he cares about the big money
people in this country because he is one
it wants to be one of the oligarchs
oligarchs don't like unions oligarchs
don't respect workers oligarchs don't
want to pay what labor is worth to
people who give the labor
good stewards of business can do that
but oligarchs do not want to do that the
plutocracy who wants to suck up the all
the [__] money in this country
doesn't want to do that Donald Trump is
one of those
folks I don't know if your optimism is
better or worse for the last I don't
know 24 hours maybe
but it should be
I've been telling you to stop listening
to the [__] media and the polls for
months and months and months that
they're lying to you it's all a bunch of
[__] just like it was a bunch of
[__] last year that there was going
to be a big huge Red Wave
they are trying to convince us of
[__] lies they're trying to
discourage us they are trying to
disengage us and the media is complicit
in this by trying to appear to be
non-bias
stop trying to appear to be non-bias be
biased to the [__] truth
and the truth of the matter is
that the audio industry is [__]
changing big time and they're on the up
and up oh my God profits are just
[__] falling in and EV Vehicles Are
Gonna Change Manufacturing in this
country it's gonna fundamentally change
Manufacturing in this country
and it's likely that the three big
automakers
are gonna cash in
big time on EVS in this country I don't
know it's probably because they uh what
do they do they make cards
so those laborers who manufacture those
cars for the big three to make their
profit
in the next two decades as EVS come to
the market and surge
want their Fair [__] share and they
should get their fair share
and they should hold out as long as it
takes
to get their fair share
and more than likely those union members
and union members all around the country
are going to come to the fact that they
should probably vote for people who are
pro-union and who are pro-labor and pro
worker
and want people to earn a decent [__]
wage
they want people to not go broke because
of a [__] medical bill
huh kind of seems kind of funny huh
here's your choice vote vote for
politicians who are serious about policy
to put workers in American middle class
first or vote for the other party who
whines and [__] about their criminal
leader
which are you going to choose
huh that's a pretty simple [__]
Choice isn't it
listen to me when I tell you this
this is very [__] important and the
media is not going to tell you this
Talking Heads are not going to tell you
this
help people in the in the Republican or
the Democratic party are not going to
tell you this I will tell you this
because it is a real raw [__] truth
if we do our job as a democracy
and engage in the ballot Donald Trump is
going to get [__] trounced next year
[__] trounced
put it in the goddamn Doubt Me section
I don't know if you watched the Stark
difference between Donald Trump and Joe
Biden with these workers
but there is a stark difference
and it is going to have a ripple effect
throughout the country if we do our job
which is engage
in the rhetoric that's right I said it
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em they
don't like it they don't like people
don't like when when you oh Tony you and
your rhetoric yes me and my [__]
rhetoric you goddamn right
it's time that we fight for our [__]
country it's time that we fight for our
[__] democracy here
enough of the [__]
of of these [__] lying to our
country
it's enough of it
let's get out in front of it let's fight
like we [__] want to have it
democracy
stop pussy-footing around stop [__]
beating around the bush stop white glove
in these son of a [__] and get in the
fight at the battle at the ballot
it's time
am I rabble-rousing I'm so [__]
lutely should we RAB arouse you goddamn
right we should
I only watch two clips of the Republican
debate last night and I know exactly
what happened I could tell you exactly
what happened at the Ronald Reagan
Library last night and I only watched
two clips
Chris Christie did his best on stage to
appear to be the only one that will
fight back against Trump and every
single one of them [__] besides
Chris Christie capitulated to [__]
Russia and Putin in the Ronald Reagan
Library
I didn't even watch the [__] and I know
what happened
they are predictably unpredictable folks
it does not take a genius to understand
what they are going to say when they are
going to say it and how they are going
to say it
this morning their entire impeachment
inquiry is falling apart at the seams
yesterday was the death nail in their
impeachment inquiry when Jason Smith
stood in front of a press Corps and
couldn't even explain why the piece of
evidence that is so important to them
from 2017 has nothing to do with Joe
Biden being vice president or a
candidate for president of the United
States
it all fell apart
Jason Smith's face and the reason why is
because Jason Smith is a [__] clown
and a joker
and if the people in Jason Smith's
District here in Missouri had any kind
of [__] backbone and saw that clip
they would fire him next year
they would either primary him or elect
the Democrat one of the two
he's not fit to be in office
neither is Jim comer or James Jim Jordan
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
for that reason alone but he is inept
too we see that in the hearing today
they don't even know they don't even
know how to [__] run the procedure of
a goddamn hearing
they didn't even see it when Daniel
Goldman was going to submit to Devin
Archer testimony that they wanted the
Republicans wanted the Devon aren't your
testimony why do you think they had it
behind closed doors and hoping they
could hide the transcript
the saddest part is we don't yell and
scream and get at the top of our lungs
in real life I'm not just talking about
on Twitter on social media and let
people know how much of a [__] joke
these goddamn Republicans are
then they won't hear it
they're gonna watch Fox News and Fox
News is going to show two clips where
look the Republicans are going in Peach
bad and and they're not
they're not they're not gonna are they
gonna bring Jonathan Turley on to figure
out why he said there's no evidence
to impeach Joe Biden I mean Jonathan
turley's on Fox News all the time all
the [__] time
but this morning he's a witness in
congress not some dumb [__] on Fox News
so this morning he tells the truth in
front of the world and in front of the
committee that there's no evidence to
impeach Joe Biden
that's that's why we have an inquiry to
uh to gather up the evidence no dummy
you have evidence to get an impeachment
inquiry on a vote on the house floor
that's what you do
there has to be an impeachable offense
to I don't know inquire about it
bone-headedry 101 here that we're seeing
not a [__] shred of evidence
against Joe Biden even the evidence that
they have is from 2017
. okay let me let me give you an idea
about Joe Biden and his his history of
being in the private sector
between the years of 2017 and 2019 was
the only years and the last half a
century that Joe Biden wasn't a public
figure and a politician those years
those years right there that's it
every other year he was either a senator
running for president vice president or
the president of the United States you
got it are you clear on that only those
two years and those are the two years
that Republicans are gonna somehow come
up with some sort of impeachable offense
because he was on the phone with
somebody
you people have lost your [__] minds
you need to wake the [__] up and pluck
your head out of your ass and realize
you are being lied to by the Republicans
you're not maca
you're being lied to that to think that
you're manga
wild stuff in our country as we are at
the intersection of WrestleMania and
real life and I've got a ton of Clips to
show you
this morning I want to show you the clip
of Jason Smith absolutely destroying any
chance that they had of convincing the
country that Joe Biden should be
impeached it's incredible and you know
what the crazy part about it is the
craziest part about that clip is that
it's an NBC News correspondent actually
doing his job the way that the media
should do it
asking a very pointed question about a
piece of evidence that the Republicans
claim from 2017 is why they are
launching a impeachment acquiry without
voting for an impeachment inquiry
and it's all faring apart at the scenes
this morning as Jamie Raskin asked
to have Webb Parnes and Rudy Giuliani
subpoena to come to the hearing so that
they can question them
oh God damn they don't want that they
don't want the Devon Archer testimony
submitted in the evidence nope they
don't want that
even though it was it was lead Parnes
and Rudy Giuliani at the behesta Trump
that went and sought out
information
to falsely accuse Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden of somehow doing the opposite of
what happened in berezma when Joe Biden
was vice president the opposite
maybe stealing stealing his laptop
laptop laptop laptop remember they used
to bring that up all the time
not anymore they definitely don't want
people like Rudy Giuliani who was the
one who was put in charge of stealing
Hunter Biden's laptop
now that Hunter Biden has sued Rudy
Giuliani
since they put the discovery all out on
the internet
of the laptop
they're in big trouble here and we
should not we should not take the shovel
out of their hand when they are digging
their political grave keep going
[__] please keep going shut down the
government continue with your pretend
impeachment
and your pretend Union rallies holy
actual [__] keep doing that
you you you really think that you're
convincing
anyone other than your die-hard cultist
that this [__] is true
and I'm telling you folks get out there
and talk to people I know sometimes it's
hard
to have discussions with people who just
are not [__] tethered in reality but
we have to make a move here
we have to be talking about this
we have to make inroads in our democracy
for the truth
no matter how inconvenient it may be for
the media I don't give a [__]
they can be biased to the truth
it is a thing that they can do
and that they should do
just like yesterday when Jason Smith
representative Jason Smith was
questioned
about evidence that he says is the
reason why Joe Biden shouldn't be
impeached
and not only does he not answer the
question he looks like a total inept
fool because he is
that's the long and the short of it they
don't know how to govern they don't want
to govern they don't care about
constituency they don't care about
Americans they don't give a [__] about
you they don't care about your families
they don't want to save the children
they don't care about [__] abortion
they don't give a [__] about any of that
stuff they don't care about morals just
go look at Lauren bobert giving hand
jobs in a goddamn theater and then
telling us what we can and can't do
[__] out of here with this nonsense this
it's time that our country call [__]
on the entire party of [__]
because that's all it is is lies
up and down one side and the other
and really honestly if you're standing
anywhere
in front of a microphone or on a stage
or you're in a government and you claim
to be a republican you're no better than
any of the rest of them none of them
none of them
if you're not leaving the Republican
party now
you're one of them
you're a joker you're a clown even Mitch
McConnell has to go to the floor
laughs
it's so funny to watch Mitch McConnell
speak now because he's trying so hard
not to glitch right Mitch McConnell used
to be really boring before
but now he's really boring when he's
really trying hard not to glitch
even glitchy mitchie's like look man if
you shut down the government don't you
know that that's gonna hurt border
security where do you think where do you
think funding from border security comes
from the [__] federal government you
[__] pass a stop Gap they're not
gonna pass a stop yet they're not going
to pass a CR they can't the reason why
is because Donald Trump won't let them
how don't you people know this
it's a cult it's a cult it's a cult it's
a cult and Kevin McCarthy is not the
speaker
Donald Trump is the Speaker of the House
he controls Kevin McCarthy with the cult
stop
Donald Trump is going to shut down the
government and he will only when he says
to reopen it will it be reopened
folks we have an authoritarian party in
our country and they are listening full
stop to an authoritarian right now as we
speak
one part of our of our legislative
branch is being controlled by an
authoritarian who isn't even elected
representative
what do you think is going to happen if
you if you put him in charge of the
federal government you think he's going
to do anything different than what he's
doing now
do you think he's gonna all of a sudden
oh well you know what he might he might
just change his ways
if we put him in he'll be presidential
we gave him four years to do that [__]
and he couldn't manage to do anything
besides give the richest people in this
country tax breaks and to tell us to
inject ourselves with bleach
to cure covet that's about the long or
the short of it folks the only good
thing Donald Trump has ever done for our
country is destroy Ron desantis's career
that's it period That's the only good
thing he's done
in the last six years is destroy Ron
DeSantis that's it
that's one thing Donald Trump gets
credit for I believe I'm gonna give him
credit
good for you buddy thank you very much
why don't you go ahead and ruin the rest
of their careers too well I mean you
didn't destroy Mike Pence's career so
that's not bad yeah it's like a close
second
now you gotta look for the Silver
Linings don't you
it can't all be negative some of it has
to be good and it is folks
I've been watching what these
chuckleheads have been flailing around
for the last two weeks and I'm telling
you
I'm telling you the country is where
you're at
is it frustrating to some people about
their personal economy sure
inflation sure
but I don't believe that this country is
going to trade away a little bit of
hardship for the long game of democracy
they're not gonna do it
people love this country people love our
constitution people want to make
progress people want to get to a
position in this country where there is
more equity and inclusion and diversity
it is the strength of our democracy it
is the strength of our nation
it will continue to be over and over and
over time and time again it will never
stop being the reason why we are deemed
the greatest country on Earth
as flawed as our system may seem
as frustrating as our system of
government may be at times
especially when we're at the
intersection of WrestleMania and real
life like we are right now
but it's worth every single inch of the
fight
and you must muster up enough to fight
for it
and it is up to us the people to make
sure
that these authoritarian Republican
Nazis do not get their hands on power
because they're showing us exactly what
they're going to do
they're showing us exactly how they
would run our country
listen in Donald Trump's first term the
one thing that we had working for us is
we had him selecting people around him
that knew a little bit about governance
do you think that's what he's going to
choose this time
do you think he's gonna choose the best
of the best which even his best of his
best last time were [__] Absolute Total
[__]
it would be much worse this time
much worse
much more ineffective
they would be jackinging for their own
power they would be jockeying to to let
the authoritarian put them in power they
wouldn't be jockeying for the American
people
they wouldn't be they wouldn't be
working hard
to do right by the American people by
the American worker by the American
Veteran
by the working middle class
by the people who spent their whole
lives working and now are on Social
Security and Medicare
for the young people who need to be
educated in this country they're not
going to work for them they only work
for themselves
and that is no more evident than this
morning in this hearing as it falls
apart at the seams that Jill Biden is
not going to be impeached and the reason
why is Republican lies are crumbling
right out from underneath them and
they're jumping on rakes this morning
and I'm going to show it to you here on
the Tony Michaels podcast so don't go
anywhere and make sure you're subscribed
to the Tony Michaels podcast here on
YouTube click that button now click the
like button now and you know if you
dislike it you can hit the thumbs down
button too hey sure sure just get
engaged in your democracy one way or the
other one way to do it is to watch this
show every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours right here on YouTube
go to the Tony michaels.com follow us
everywhere I want to thank everyone last
night for all the shots that you that
you sent in and I have some venmo
venmo chats excuse me to show you
and today from yesterday so don't go
anywhere we will be right back I promise
we're not going anywhere I'm going to
show you a ton of these clips we got to
get to them right after this break
[Music]
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
foreign
oh boy oh boy oh boy
the Republican party is stepping on at
rakes this morning they stepped on a big
rig yesterday and I'm gonna get to those
clips but I want to show you one link
real quick before we get started here is
the Tony michaels.com don't forget to
subscribe here at the top I will send
you notice of all the stuff I got a
refresh here there we go now there's the
new episode there's a new episode every
single day every single one of them
right there at the very top if you want
to get in on the action if you want to
help support the show I appreciate it
this microphone could not stay on
without you if you want to buy me a shot
I posted some pictures of the shots I
was taking last night on social media
also if you want to get in on the venmo
chat I have a I think I have a couple to
get to today if you want to have your
message up on the screen during the show
just go to the tonymichaels.com get in
on the venmo Super Chat there and then
support me on patreon tomorrow morning
we're gonna do the pre-show that's right
we do an hour pre-show it's a producer's
corner on Discord every single month
Monday and Friday and tomorrow's Friday
we know so we will be there doing
the pre-show on the produce at the
producers corner on Discord so don't
forget to go to the Discord and become a
member and become a member at patreon
just go to the Tony michaels.com you can
find all those links there there's the
patreon link there at the top here right
here and then you pan down here's the
Discord server right there and I also
put the Discord server Link in the chat
should go to the Tony michaels.com help
support the show there I appreciate all
the support that you guys give when
you're here every single day listening
to the show engaging in the show talking
challenging me
challenging others in the chat that's
what we must do we must challenge each
other because we have to stay on top of
our game
with the
fascists foreign
fascist but you know I'm not going to
complain too much when they're stepping
on rakes I'm excited about it here is uh
here is Missouri Representative Jason
Smith absolutely stepping on a rake
yesterday he set the tone for the
impeachment hearing or pretend the Sham
impeachment inquiry hearing with no vote
this morning here's yesterday he was
asked a couple simple questions and the
Republicans case to impeach Joe Biden
falls apart right in front of this
microphone watch Mr chairman uh
questions just about the timing of all
of this you're talking about a
two-tiered system of justice
if I'm not mistaken August 7 2020 Bill
Barr was the attorney general and Donald
Trump was the president so
explain to me where the two-tiered
system of justice comes into play and
then the WhatsApp message you have I
believe is dated June 6 2017 Joe Biden
is not vice president or even a
candidate for president at that time so
where is the direct connection to some
sort of criminal malfeasance with uh-oh
oh man this reporter has looked at uh
years he's like oh that evidence is from
2017. I wonder who was the vice
president and running for president of
the president in 2017. who could it
possibly be
now this is a great example what the
media should be doing
right this is a great example of how the
media should be doing their job okay
here you go it's [__] beautiful watch
Jason Smith as he realizes he's in front
of a microphone there is recording and
he's going to look like a total dumb
[__] Within These two pieces of evidence
well I think the facts speak for
themselves there's over 700 pages of
examples of where people should be very
concerned when you're talking about
um
uh the what was your first question
uh he is he is so [__] up by the fact
that he just got all the evidence that
they think is the reason why Joe Biden
is going to be impeached dunked in the
[__] trash
just absolutely dunked in the [__]
trash
not get it's gonna get better this is
the Prelude this this is yesterday okay
remember this is yesterday and this this
is one chairman of the three chairman
that is responsible for impeaching Joe
Biden this morning the hearing is with
Jim
Q Anon Comer which Jim cuanon Comer is
even more feckless and ridiculous than
Jason Smith the guy you see in this clip
but listen here is Jason tries to come
up with a way to figure out how to blame
the media for the evidence that the
Republicans have that isn't actually
evidence of an impeachment
article the timing of this is August 7th
2020 Bill Barr's the Attorney General
Donald Trump's the president yeah unless
she was not a political
when obstructing the investigation it
doesn't matter who's in the white house
we need to make sure the Department of
Justice works for all people and doesn't
treat those who are politically
connected or wealthy much differently
and unfortunately we have several
examples that came forward by the two
IRS whistleblowers that proves that
people are treated differently because
they're politically but haven't you
suggest oh oh wait a second wait a
second Jason Smith so what you're saying
what you're saying is we shouldn't let
the Department of Justice treat
political crime and politically
connected people and rich people any
differently oh really
oh really Jason Smith is that what
you're saying
because I'm hearing that what's that's
what you're saying I don't know if you
actually [__] believe that or not
because when this reporter would ask you
a question about the charges leveled
against Donald Trump I bet your answer
would be exact opposite because I'm in
agreeance
with Jason Smith here that the
Department of Justice should not treat
any rich or politically connected people
any differently than me or you
that's actually what you call Justice
okay Jason Smith let's see if you get
any better at this my bet is [__] no
so that Don Joe Biden being the
president now is unfairly treating
Donald Trump in his indictments
what I'm talking about is the 700 pages
that we have before us which is all the
information that came from the IRS
whistleblowers and that's what we're
releasing right now and I'll tell you I
would encourage everyone in this room to
look at those 700 Pages if you think
it's okay with what's in it then we live
on two different planets can you explain
the timing then of the August 6th
WhatsApp message why is that evidence of
some wrongdoing here we go here it is
here's where oh he threw the rake out
and now he's gonna just [__] jump on
it watch not an expert on the timeline I
would love to have
um president
what was that Jason Smith what was that
you're not a what on the timeline what's
in it and we live on two different
planets listen can you explain the
timing then of the August 6th what's
that message why is that evidence of
somebody doing I'm not an expert on the
timeline I would love oh he's not an
expert on the timeline oh
he's not an expert on the timeline well
ain't that about a [__] I thought I
thought we were hearing from the
chairman who is releasing the 700 pages
of evidence which proves without a doubt
the Joe Biden should be impeached and
imprisoned sent to gitmo and hung
I thought that's what you were doing oh
well let's get an expert on the [__]
timeline here let's see if we can find
someone who can point to us who the [__]
was the president and who is running for
president but in particular who was not
the vice president or running for
president in 2017. I wonder if anyone
out there anyone anyone could be an
expert on a calendar and tell us what
the [__] that means
love to have
um President Biden and his family tell
us about all the timelines oh it's
really really yeah unfortunate that we
see so many meetings and so many phone
calls uh that involved uh around
official activity that the vice
president has been participating in and
then big sums of Money Follows later but
if he's not the president or the vice
president at that time
where where's the wrong doing he wasn't
even a candidate for president at that
time
at that time sure you think I actually
think Jason Smith is like oh [__] you're
right we didn't even consider that I
mean we are so we are so [__] wildly
after after Joe Biden to make sure that
we compare him to Donald Trump so that
way when you go [__] elect somebody
we can say yeah Donald Trump's a corrupt
[__] he's a criminal but so is
Joe Biden that's what all this is about
anyways folks this entire [__] thing
that's all it's about that's all it's
about is because Joe Biden is not a
criminal he's not corrupt but the only
way that they can get Donald Trump
elected is to make him seem that way
period period so that way when people go
vote for Trump they're like yeah I'm
voting for Trump he's a criminal he's a
[__] felon he [__] he's a
treasonous piece of [__] he tried to
overthrow our government he stole our
[__] nuclear secrets and probably
sold them but you know what Joe Biden is
a criminal too because Jason Smith said
so about a WhatsApp message in 2017 when
Joe Biden didn't even [__] he wasn't
even the vice president or running for
president good one Jason you [__]
idiot keep going keep digging do not
take the shovel out of their hands [__]
this reporter here hands Jason Smith a
goddamn Becco
to dig himself a political grave keep
going Jason it's [__] beautiful he
was a candidate yet no he wasn't on no
no August 6th of 2017.
I'm with NBC so apparently you'll never
believe us it's not about believing you
you dumb son of a [__] it's not about
believing you because you're a [__]
liar number one but number two it's
[__] in your evidence you presented
the evidence you're saying this is why
we should impeach him because of
messages that don't even breed any kind
of corruption anyways from 2017 when Joe
Biden wasn't the vice president and
wasn't running for president what
[__] political influence did Joe
Biden have in 2017
huh answer the [__] question Jason
answer it you can't I don't believe you
I'm asking you for I'm asking you a very
direct question you presented a piece of
evidence that you say came on August 6
2017 that demonstrates that Joe Biden
was using political influence to help
his son if he wasn't a political figure
at that time the first what's that
message you put up where you talk about
the brand and I'm not I'm here I'm my my
I'm completely open-minded about this
I'm asking you specifically how does
that demonstrate that there's some sort
of political influence being put over
him if at that time he is not a
political he's not an elected official
I'm definitely not going to pinpoint one
item I think we've outlined we presented
it it was your first thing that you
brought up so apparently you don't agree
with that so it's not that I don't
approve that I'm asking you to explain
it I'll take the next one I'll take the
next question this question is just way
too hard and this question is actually
undermining the entire process of us
pretending to impeach Joe Biden so let's
go to the next reporter because
obviously obviously this this reporter
here wants to ask legitimate questions
and challenge the evidence that I have
presented and to pretend to impeach Joe
Biden
Jason Smith you're a [__] joke you're
a [__] joke all day every day and you
should fi you know what as much as Bob
Menendez and George Santos should resign
which you know what as far as I can tell
Jason Smith kind of reminds me of George
Santos Danny he looks like he could be
his [__] cousin or something but
here's our and really honestly he sounds
like him too but if you if you want to
know the honest truth Jason Smith after
your performance yesterday of not even
knowing when Joe Biden was and wasn't
vice president and was and wasn't
running for president as you're
presenting evidence to impeach this
[__] you should resign
full stop just like Bob Menendez just
like George Santos and just like Mitch
McConnell and Kevin McCarthy you should
[__] resign and Lauren bobert and
Marjorie Taylor green and Matt Getz why
we're just throwing names out there why
not why [__] that I mean we might as
well
oh Jason you dumb son of a [__] now
here's the thing is it's our job is it's
our job to keep pushing this [__] out
there because these people these brain
dead [__] aren't going to watch
this [__] they're not going to watch
this [__] they're not going to just like
just like they're not going to show this
clip here from this morning of Jonathan
Turley this is this is wild [__] here
but it it's it's good stuff it's good
stuff it's only seven seconds long
here's Jonathan Turley as the first
witness in the Joe Biden impeachment
the Sham inquiry that isn't actually
acquired because there's been no vote so
it's pretending to be an inquiry but
let's listen to what Jonathan Turley
says this morning about evidence of
Articles of impeachment in fact
I do not believe that the current
evidence would support articles of
impeachment
what well wait ah wait a second wait a
second now Jonathan Turley you're
supposed to be there to support the
impeachment of Joe Biden say what you
now what you say I want to hear it again
in fact yeah I do not believe you don't
current evidence would support articles
of impeachment
that the current evidence would support
articles of impeachment
oopsie oh oopsie Jonathan you weren't
supposed to say that out loud oh my god
oh [__] now I don't know if you know who
Jonathan Durley is but Jonathan Turley
is a [__] chucklehead a goddamn Fox
News chucklehead this is the same stupid
son of a [__] that they put out in
front of the world when Republicans want
want someone to believe that a lawyer
knows everything about everything
because they're a [__] lawyer and we
just know in our timeline right now with
all the Trump lawyers who have lost
their law license been sanctioned we
just know we just know that for sure
it's not that hard to be a [__]
attorney in this country and you ain't
got to be that goddamn smart there are
good attorneys there are smart attorneys
out there but you ain't got to be smart
are good to be one that's for God damn
sure and Jonathan Turley here even
though he barely has enough brain cells
to rub together understands the fact of
the matter and the fact of the matter is
what again Jonathan in fact yeah I do
not believe right the current evidence
would support particles of impeachment
oh well [__] me running what the [__]
are they doing there then
huh what the [__] are they doing wasting
our time and our tax dollars to have a
[__] impeachment hearing without a
vote without evidence what the [__] are
they oh that's right it's all theater
it's all to convince the American people
that Joe Biden is just as corrupt and
just as big as criminal as Donald Trump
so why not vote for Donald Trump period
that's the whole [__] that's the
whole [__] scam
that's the whole [__] lie here
the entire thing that's what it is
that's what it will be it will continue
to be that and it is falling apart this
morning spectacularly oh my God you
can't imagine how easy it is for someone
like Daniel gobin or Jamie Raskin to
absolutely [__] tear these idiots
apart
it's incredible
it's incredible they they can't even
manage they can't even manage to handle
seats simple ass procedural votes in
their Committee hearing which is an
operation of the committee when the
chairman is I don't know smart enough to
understand how the [__] government
works how a committee functions [__]
James James q and on Comer couldn't even
find the goddamn Clerk
to take a road call he says do we even
have a clerk they didn't even know if
they had a clerk to take roll call votes
are you [__] [__] me
folks this is important ass [__] and I
understand the government isn't sexy and
government is boring
but when a committee chair
in a impeachment inquiry a pretend sham
impeachment inquiry which is trying to
impeach a president of the United States
who is duly elected by the people can't
even [__] get a clerk to take roll
call votes
are you [__] [__] me
and we expect that these people are
gonna keep the government open or do
anything for us in our government that
they're supposed to be representing us
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense
every American in this country should be
[__] livid this morning about what is
going on in this hearing watch this
[__] [__]
they don't know what to do I didn't hear
a motion to table
oh oh see and you know what Jamie Raskin
honestly In This Moment should have just
sat there and not said anything let them
just [__] crumble but Jamie Raskin is
even trying to throw him a bone here
because there's a motion on the table
where they have to take a roll call vote
okay that's what's happening they need
to take a vote on a motion now someone
can actually table the make a motion to
table that motion and then they can vote
on tabling the motion which means that
motion just sets aside
and gay
this is simple [__] government stuff
this isn't complicated for people to
know you just gotta know it but watch as
Jim Q Anon Comer has no [__] clue
what to do watch as Jamie Raskin tells
them they have to table the motion and
then see who chimes in other than Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan because
he realizes that they're not gonna go
anywhere without this motion to table
chairman chair recognize Miss Jordan I
moved the table of motion there's a
motion to table did you see did you see
what did you see what Jamie Raskin did
Jamie Raskin gave a smirk because he
knew they didn't know what the [__] to
do until he said what the [__] to do
watch are they task for recorded vote on
that Mr Boom this is on here it is here
it is here it is he figures for what but
in your theory about why President Biden
should be impeached I think they're
going to be an informative hearing for
you Mr Askins because we've we're going
to present evidence what evidence
there's no evidence
just sit back and let the American
people hear the see the hearing and let
the American people all right now look
you've gone over your time we're going
to have a table by the rules here okay
okay motion ten I'm glad you brought the
Box uh bank statements if we had a box
of all the foreign money
is really upset that that Jamie Raskin
pulled the visual stunt I'm going to
show you the visual stunt that he's
talking about here in a second
no listen everybody's gonna get five
minutes I'm going to present the
Witnesses
in five minutes I let the ranking member
go way over time in his opening
statement but we are going to abide by
the five minutes
there's a motion on the floor
James Comer does not even know what the
[__] is going on and the reason why
James Comer does not know what the hell
is going on because all of this isn't
real
it's not real it's not functional and
because it's not based in reality nor is
nor is it even based in the fact that we
should actually be having a hearing on
this
this is just [__] theater for Fox
News period that's it that's all it is
is is for Donald Trump to stand up and
say see see what they're doing to me see
protect me please protect me please
and it's all a [__] show it has
nothing to do with governments it has
nothing to do with their constituents it
has nothing they don't even know he
doesn't even know if he has a clerk it's
a non-debatable motion on the floor
on the motion of the table
will the clerk
we don't even have a clerk
we don't even have a clerk we didn't
need her to have a clerk to have roll
calls
are you [__] [__] me
are you [__] me he didn't even know
if he had a clerk or not these people
I'm telling you I'm telling you these
people are are just [__] clowns
full stop 100 clowns all the way around
and it ain't gonna stop and ain't gonna
stop here if you think oh well tomorrow
they'll get your [__] together
no way not gonna happen no [__] way
oh here we go here's Jamie you're asking
I believe this is the part where he's uh
he's introduced introducing the motion
to subpoena Rudy Giuliani and Lead
Barnes let's watch Donald Trump but
that's exactly what has not happened
here because they don't have the votes
because dozens of Republicans recognize
what a futile and absurd process this is
now the title of the hearing is the
basis for an impeachment inquiry of
President Joseph Biden
and yet they present us no basis at all
today even after eight months of
Investigation they've invited three
witnesses to testify not one of them is
an eyewitness to a presidential crime of
any kind not one of them is a direct
fact witness about any of the events
related to Ukraine and barisma not one
of them has participated in the eight
months of Investigation
in which our distinguished chairman has
publicly boasted that he received 100 of
everything he asked for and I quote
every subpoena that I've signed as
chairman of the house oversight
committee over the last five months
we've gotten 100 of what we've requested
whether it's with the FBI with the banks
or with treasury that means we are the
real Witnesses here in fact
the committee has received 12
000 pages of bank records here they are
right in front of us print so here's
here's the stunt with the boxes here's
the boxes that have the bank records
that Jim Jim q and on Comer says he got
a hundred percent of from his subpoenas
that's what it is there behind Raskin as
you see there in the boxes that's what
that's what Comer was talking about
that's what he was so pissed off about
is this visual stunt that that Raskin
pulled which Democrats need to get
better at this they're getting better at
this
all right you're going to see a clip
from Daniel Goldman here trying to
submit some evidence of the desk Devin
Archer excuse me Devin Archer testimony
which the Republicans tried to hide
behind closed doors but let's continue
with draskin here with this clip trying
to double-sided and not a single page
shows a dime going to President Joe
Biden we've received 2 000 pages of
stars reports the chairman subpoenaed
we've held hearings and conducted
interviews with everybody from 100
Biden's business partners to a federal
agent assigned to that investigation and
still we found no evidence of wrongdoing
by President Biden if the Republicans
had a Smoking Gun or even a dripping
water pistol
I
can't tell you how [__] great that
line is if the Republicans had a Smoking
Gun or even a dripping water pistol
doesn't that perfectly describe the
Republican party in 2023
a dripping water pistol bloop bloop
bloop can't even squirt that
[__] trigger doesn't work you
know what I'm talking about you know
you're a kidney and them shitty ass
water guns she had to dunk in they had
the little thing on the back that you
pulled out the little plug and that
[__] thing broke off right eventually
it broke off but after about two tries
you dunk it in the water and it's a
little bitty thing it's like squirt
squirting it's like it didn't even come
out it doesn't even come out that's a
perfect example and a perfect
description of the Republican party in
2023. they would be presenting it today
but they've got nothing on Joe Biden all
they can do is return to the thoroughly
demolished lie that Rudy Giuliani and
Donald Trump launched five years ago the
barisma conspiracy theory a fairy tale
so Preposterous that one of its main
authors love parnas has now disowned and
reputed there's there's right before
that Jamie Raskin put the motion on the
floor to subpoena Le Parnes
and web partners and re Giuliani uh and
it's it's it would again the reason why
is because of the statements that lead
Parnes has made about barisma and what
the goal of Rudy Giuliani was and who
was at the direction or who who he was
at the direction of to lie about barisma
but let's continue with more Jamie
Raskin Clips here let's go a dozen of uh
our colleagues on the Republican side
have already called for impeachment I'm
struck by the fact that of the four
expert Witnesses brought together today
not a single one of them argued that a
sufficient Quantum of evidence exists
today to justify the impeachment of
President Biden is there any precedent
in our country for launching an
impeachment inquiry absent evidence of
wrongdoing by the president
um no and in fact I would just point out
that with Richard Nixon and Bill Clinton
and president Trump in 2019. here we go
Full House authorize those impeachments
oh son of a [__] ah son of a [__] so
it's not a legitimate impeachment
inquiry is what you're saying oh well
[__] me ain't that just convenient
I don't know if you're you're noticing
where this is going or not but this is
not going well
this is not going well
[Laughter]
this is not going well and for the
Republicans The Rake steppers of the
House of Representatives More Jamie are
asking let's keep going Donald Trump but
that's exactly what has not happened
here because they don't have the votes
because dozens of Republicans recognize
what a futile and absurd process this is
now the title of the hearing is the
basis for an impeachment inquiry of
President Joseph Biden
and yet they present us no basis at all
today even after eight months of
Investigation there's more Jamie are
asking I'm telling you these clips are
going to be big on the internet
um if you're not finding these clips
then then you should go out and find
them now here's
oh boy here's a clip of uh James Q Anon
Comer not being able to do his job
I thought task for recorded vote on that
Mr chairman this is on the subpoena of
the two key figures Rudy Giuliani in
love partners he figures for what but in
your theory about now see all these
clips are going to be about the same
yeah because they're just repeats of him
absolutely owning them yeah here's the
one I want here's the one I want this is
the one I'm looking for
they all look the same it's all Jamie
ranskin absolutely [__] owning these
idiots watch this and you think I'm
being harsh here's what some Republicans
have had to say over the last week about
the actions of the Republicans as they
watch up close quote the dysfunction
caucus at work in the words of our GOP
colleague from Nebraska Don Bacon clown
show foolishness terribly misguided
stupidity failure to lead lunatics
disgraceful new low pathetic enabling
chairman XI people that have serious
issues those folks don't have a plan
show just how broken they are and
individuals that just want to burn the
whole place down now if I said any of
these things they'd probably take my
words down but these are Republicans
talking about Republicans so
ah Jamie ranskin with the [__]
receipts am I right am I right or am I
right with the [__] absolute receipts
listen folks this idea that they were
going to have an impeachment inquiry
right at the time that they were going
to shut down the entire government was a
really really stupid idea what a dumb
idea this was
how ridiculous do you think that it has
to be and how ridiculous do you think
that it has to get
for them to not understand that right
before they're going to piss the
American people off they're gonna [__]
on them with lies too are you kidding me
go for it keep going don't stop here's a
here's another example of how governance
actually works and James Comer doesn't
understand how it works and Daniel
Goldman handing him his ass
point of border down here Mr chairman
chair recognizes Mr Donald for five
years
oh uh oh here's where is where Daniel
Goldman is going to explain to James
Comer the chairman of the committee that
he can't he can't just skate over a
point of order it's a point of order
it's about the actual hearing itself
let's keep going here let's watch Daniel
Goldman at work five minutes
you're out of order Mr Goldman when
you're when your time is
Mr Donald for five minutes is it being
introduced there recognizes Mr Donald's
for five minutes Byron that you're sure
the rules were okay so here's what's
happening Daniel Goldman here is trying
to submit this piece of paper and what
is on this piece of paper is the
transcript of the testimony of Devin
Archer the guy who was supposed to blow
this whole thing open remember that oh
man remember the day that he walked in
the [__] Court he looks like Hunter
Biden kinda Devin Archer you know I mean
slick back hair suit you know what I
mean he looks like an [__] I'm just
saying Devin Archer looks like a [__]
[__] if you're not aware Devin Archer
was actually on a bunch of federal
charges and he's been out on appeal and
the government is he lost all those
appeals and the government's trying to
get that [__] in prison it is a
perfect example Devin Archer is the
perfect example of a two-tier justice
system and the Republicans thought that
this guy was going to come in and give
them all the evidence that they needed
against Joe Biden that Joe Biden was
working in coordination with Hunter
Biden to somehow take government
payments or some dumb [__] as brides
which none of the payments that were
sent to Hunter Biden were [__] bribes
you can guaran goddamn tea if those were
bribes David Weiss the [__] special
counsel in Delaware would have charged
Hunter Biden with [__] bribes and
foreign and foreign relations
violations than just some dumb ass
trumped-up [__] gun charges period
but that's why they didn't did the Devon
Archer testimony behind closed doors I
said that morning when Devin Archer was
walking into to give the testimony that
the reason why they were doing it behind
closed doors is because they didn't want
those transcripts out because those
transcripts would show that Joe Biden
did nothing [__] wrong there's no
evidence of it and that's what it shows
and Daniel Goldman here is trying to
submit that testimony into this hearing
so that that the American people can see
that this is all a [__] scam and
James q and on Comer doesn't want that
testimony submitted as evidence and the
reason why is because it blows apart
their entire [__] narrative all of it
require you thank you chairman no
yes for a point of order they absolutely
do care recognizes the Motions
Mr chairman I request this clock be set
back to five minutes
Mr chairman can I just make a
parliamentary inquiry then are we not to
make points of order on either side
during you keep speaking about no
evidence why don't you all just listen
I'm trying to introduce evidence
you've already entered you've already
had your is it share of evidence Mr Mr
Donald's
uh-oh oh man oh man isn't it funny when
Daniel Goldman tells James Gomer the
chairman the supposed chairman of the
pretend committee here
of what a point of order is and why the
porn of order is to submit this as
evidence
listen here's the thing
and I don't know if the Republicans have
caught on to this
but they're amateurs at this
they're [__] amateurs they do not
know how to do this
they're not aware they're way [__]
out of their league way out in front of
their skis here on what the [__] is real
and what isn't
and because they don't even know how to
run a [__] hearing
they just keep jumping on rates and
really honestly Daniel Goldman Jamie
Raskin and the Republicans themselves
should just keep throwing them out there
folks our government is going to be
dysfunctional for a long time for the
next year
maybe maybe you know tell you know
January of 2025
it's going to be very dysfunctional they
ain't gonna get [__] done it's going to
hurt the country but the reason why that
is is because people went and voted for
[__] clowns and the clowns won the
[__] party
they own that party
and they own it in the name of Donald
Trump
and that's just how it [__] is and if
we don't keep pointing it out and
pointing it out and pointing it out it
is it is not going to have an effect in
this country and we have to keep yelling
and screaming about how [__]
ridiculous these people are and how much
of a [__] show this is it's not even
real
it's not even [__] real
it's about it's about as real
it's about as real
as
Ron DeSantis
and his sincerity I don't know if you've
seen this this is a clip from the debate
last night it's not actually the bait
it's off screen here look what Rhonda
Santos is doing in this video
I'll turn it off here if you watch oh
boy you know what it's a good thing he's
in California because didn't he make
this [__] a felony in Florida in this
illegal in Florida for a guy to wear
makeup look at this guy look at this guy
how much makeup does Ron need good Lord
this is some wild drag ass [__] you know
what I mean
I mean you know I'm just saying what do
you want from me I'm just trying to
[__] what I don't I don't know if
he's trying to if he's got to confirm
his pronouns when he's when he's putting
this much makeup on but God damn God
damn Ron
[__] Jokers it's all theater it's all
[__] all the time it never stops
with these [__] and it's never
not
they're pieces of trash they don't care
about the American people they don't
care about what's real and what's lies
and what's not they don't give a [__]
about any of that
they only care about their own power
that's it that's it
um here's another clip I'm going to turn
this way down this one because it's like
really loud
but here is the clip speaking of [__]
fake
oh my God oh my I can't tell you because
like a lot of people are really [__]
pissed off that Trump goes to Detroit
and Trump [__] he goes to a non-union
plant he goes to a non-union plant and
pays people to hold Union signs to act
like that they're in the [__] Union
to make it appear as if the UAW supports
him which they do not
they don't support him I'm going to show
you a couple different clips here but
here's this first one here let me uh let
me mute this thing uh so that you guys
can can see this and here is here is a
video of Donald Trump at this um this
plant
all right let's play this here you see
him up there on the stage just standing
there
you can't move around it's almost like
it's almost like he's kind of old and
feeble you know what I mean
like you think that a guy you know who
was fit to be president would be kind of
like dancing around having fun doing
spends you know shaking hands right he
wouldn't just be standing in one place
swiveling back and forth like I mean
honestly I I he he hadn't been able to
barely put a sentence together he
thought Jeb Bush ran against him he
thought Obama ran against him [__] last
night at this rally he was saying that
electric motors if we put electric
motors in boats and they sink oh man
everyone's gonna get electrocuted in the
water because you know that hole
I guess he thinks too much about putting
a toaster in a bathtub or something is
what this guy's doing but I'm going to
give you the headlines here or the story
here from The Daily Press a journalist
from the Detroit News made a trip down
to the rally and began speaking with
those in attendance
at this non-union plant pretending to be
a union rally including one of those as
a quote holding
a union members for Trump placard right
yeah you can see they're holding those
during a discussion with the reporter
though it appeared that the sign holders
was not even a member of the Union huh
isn't that kind of funny see you're
telling me you're telling me that it's
all [__] come on that can't be right
now the other holding the Auto Workers
for trump card was not employed as an
auto worker so you're telling me the
people holding the signs in this clip
union members for Trump and and Otter
workers for Trump aren't those things
that they're paid to hold those signs
come on it's almost like Donald Trump is
a total [__] fraud here the event
estimates estimates predict was intended
by 500 Trump supporters there were 500
people there folks 500 people were at
this plant here's the problem this plant
is called Drake Enterprises
and it has a it has a Workforce of a
hundred and fifty
a hundred and fifty
but apparently there was 500 people
there that was the report but there's
only 150 members I wonder if they paid
people to come there
and hold signs people who weren't union
members people who weren't who weren't
[__] Auto Workers I wonder you know
just I wonder if that's the case could
it be could it be that Donald Trump
couldn't attract a UAW crowd even if he
[__] wanted to could it be that
workers in this country want nothing to
do with Donald Trump could that be what
it is or is it that he's [__] jealous
it could be he could be [__] jealous
that's a possibility I mean I think it
could be a possibility I don't know
let's let's see what some of the UAW
members that are out on the picket line
have to say let's see what they have to
say
Donald Trump being reelected would be
very very bad for unions in Wisconsin I
know he wouldn't be fighting for us like
Trump went to the non-union and our
president came here so let's go UAW
uh-oh oh man it seems like the union
members are on to Donald Trump what do
you think
do you think the rest of the country
would be on the Donald Trump oh my God
folks I keep telling you over and over
and over again quit believing their lies
that you keep hearing in the media that
Donald Trump is [__] neck and neck
with Joe Biden he is not it is a [__]
lie
those polls are all [__] full stop
100 complete utter [__] this race is
not even [__] close when it comes to
the American people the American people
know who's working for them the American
people know who they want to work for
him when given the choice of Joe Biden
and Donald Trump they're going to chose
Joe Biden every goddamn day of the week
and twice on Sunday because he actually
goes to church instead of pretending to
go to church that's right
that's right
and that's the [__] truth uh you want
some more truth the union boss Sean you
want some more truth about the UAW
and Donald Trump and how much they like
him watch this the union boss Sean Fain
doesn't seem to be with you though he
didn't want to you don't want to meet
with you I talked to some folks outside
I didn't know that they said they were
mad oh yeah he didn't know that Donald
Trump didn't know that he didn't want to
meet with him he sure as hell [__]
did new listen listen he did know he
wouldn't meet with oh I didn't know that
I didn't hear that he didn't want to but
if he didn't want to meet with me then I
don't like him very much but uh
oh you you [__] betulent little [__]
you're such a [__] child what a
[__] child if he doesn't want to meet
with him I don't like him very much
as if the UAW [__] president gives a
good God damn if Donald Trump likes him
listen a good Mark in this country that
you're a decent [__] like one
one thing one thing like a low bar to
reach right that you're a decent
[__] is if Donald Trump doesn't
like you very much if Donald Trump
doesn't like you very much by God you're
getting there to be a decent [__]
person
let me show you let me show you the
difference here though
let me show you something let me show
you the president there that they're
talking about of the UAW and and tell me
if you can figure out
um this guy here if you look on the on
the left here that's the UAW president
who is this other guy standing next to
him with a UAW he's got a hat on
is that a hat that says UAW I can't tell
can you can you look close I am [__]
it's almost like I know this guy here
can you do you recognize this guy hmm
seems kind of funny seems like the UAW
present there is standing in solidarity
with the president of the United States
because the president United States is
standing in solidarity with those
workers
those Americans the middle class workers
what a [__] joke Trump is
what a [__] joke the Republican party
is if you want to know the [__]
honest truth
that's just how it is they're a [__]
joke
and to think that they're popular and
their policies are popular
is ridiculous
ridiculous way way out in a different
Universe if you believe Donald Trump and
the Republican Party are popular in this
country and here's here's a good example
of one clip from last night's debate
with Ron DeSantis listen to the facts
that she drops right before the question
it's incredible and then look at Rhonda
Santos's reaction when she drops the
fact so
and could come down to less than
thousand votes in three states
abortion was not
in 2022 Republicans lost all of them
next year abortion will likely be on
what is that [__] Bassy makes
does he have a butt plug-in I'm serious
it's almost like this guy's got a remote
control vibrating butt plug-in and his
campaign when they want him to [__]
smile they push the button he's like
doesn't it feel like that I mean I never
I've never had a vibrating but I've
never had a vibrating but like I'm just
saying that
that if there was one that might be what
it would be like you know what I mean
you know what I mean I mean really
honestly look at this guy's face look at
this game hmm
and he does it like weird moments like
at the end when he's talking you know
what I mean um some people are saying
sure Tony sure are you talking about me
in a butt plug
believe what you want to believe I don't
care
you're not gonna hurt my feelings but
Rhonda Sant is here can you imagine if
it was outed that this is actually what
is happening
I'm telling you I I I got it man there's
something going on here can he really be
this [__] weird with that face that
smile that he is hmm
I get so hard I don't know I mean it's
possible
it's possible
let's let's look at him uh round out the
weird ass butt plug smile on the ballot
in Arizona that is a must-win state
Governor DeSantis how are you going to
selection doesn't it look like it that's
what it looks like I'm telling you it's
[__] weird that's [__] weird here
let's see if um let's see there's
another I thought there was another one
there was a video of Ronda zantes doing
this stupid weird-ass smile
um
I'll find it here in a minute I'll find
it here in a minute but here's
speaking of Ron DeSantis in a new ad
here's a new ad that's just dropped uh
let's watch this and you know who else
is missing in action Donald Trump is
missing in action he should be on the
stage tonight he owes it to you oh let's
keep going to defend his record were
they added 7.8 trillion to the debt that
set the stage for the inflation that we
have now I'm Joe Biden and I approve
this message
and you know who else is missing in
action
thank you Rhonda Santos uh here's
another clip from the um this is one of
the only clips that I really needed from
the debate now this is Chris Christie a
lot of people like this this is the
Donald Duck clip if you haven't seen the
Donald Duck clip here's the Donald Duck
clip from Chris Christie last night at
the Ronald Reagan Library the only one
that really was standing up for anything
that Ronald Reagan would stand up for
but let's watch we need to go on over
back in our suburbs people are
threatened there we need it in our rural
areas people feel threatened there and
we need it in Washington DC also and
Donald Trump should be here to answer
for that but he's not and I want to look
at that camera right now tell you Donald
I know you're watching you can't help
yourself I know you're watching okay and
you're not here tonight not because of
polls and not because of your
indictments you're not here tonight
because you're afraid of being on the
stage and Defending Your record you're
ducking these things and let me tell you
what's going to happen you keep doing
that no one up here is going to call you
Donald Trump anymore we're going to
Donald Duck all right
I mean a lot of people thought that was
a great clip but come on Chris Christie
it's [__] that's shitty my butt plug
joke is way better than the Donald Duck
joke isn't it uh Colin here on Facebook
says he is a butt plug I'm not assuming
you're talking about Ron DeSantis
um you know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
say that that's not that might be true
at one point Somewhere In The
Reincarnation of Ronda santis he may
have been a butt plug in some other life
or something that maybe that's what the
face is about I don't know I mean it's
possible but Chris Christie here with
the stupid Donald Duck joke are you
buying this stuff
this Donald Duck joke a lot of people
thought that was great right I was like
that's that sucks he's ducking his
responsibility you know I get what he's
trying to say and I get that he's going
after Trump I was like oh man that that
was shitty yeah it wasn't very good at
all
I'm just saying I'm just saying
um here here Gabe Sanchez has um a clip
from Rhonda Santos last night with the
with the the butt plug face Republicans
all of them next year abortion will
likely be on the ballot do you ever look
at someone and wonder why what is going
on inside their head my name is Anita
ladies
[Music]
oh Gabe Sanchez with the slam dunk on
Rhonda Santos that's [__] hilarious I
didn't see that until just now and just
now is when I when I saw that and
ah oh boy God damn
whew
okay let's see if we can find I there
was another video of Ron DeSantis having
a really really um horrible moment
trying to not give the butt plugs butt
plug smile
um is that it no and that's not the one
I I know there was a video this morning
I tried to retweet all this stuff you
know so I have it ready to go
um but you know it's not always a easy
to find this stuff back just give me a
minute would you do
yeah let's see maybe I won't be able to
find it
[Music]
it really does look like it like there's
someone backstage they're like okay
push the smile button like literally
that's it probably is like a little
remote control that has like one of them
uh label makers and it says smile button
so they just push it when they need him
I think so Maybe I'm Wrong I think I'm
right uh let's go to the more important
clips though of the Republican debate
from last night which is um actual uh
clips of people telling the truth I
don't know that might help you know what
I mean like Gavin Newsom I love this
thing where where they're gonna they're
gonna try to debate Gavin Newsom have
you seen this Rhonda Santos is going to
debate Kevin Newsom oh my God I can't
tell you how excited I would be for for
for Ron DeSantis to debate Gavin Newsom
um and the reason why is because
Gavin Newsom I don't know he knows what
the hell he's talking about
like the majority of the time
and
Republicans really don't so here is here
is DeSantis and then Newsome afterwards
giving commentary uh let's listen my
wife and I have met three people who
have been mugged on the street
well I I want him and this may be an
opportunity I appreciate uh to look up
uh Jacksonville Florida and he may want
a familiarize himself with Miami Florida
oh his homicide rights which are 100
higher than San Francisco crime rates in
his own backyard he has a higher
homicide rate Statewide 16 percent
higher than the state of California uh
for whatever reason he didn't bring up
Tennessee Arkansas South Carolina it
didn't bring up Texas all with higher
crime rates in the state of California
uh this is an old Trope I mean if you're
in New York so I think people are
getting a little exhausted uh by the
fact that we're focusing on New York's
uh crime rate and not the crime rate and
these other republican-led cities in
Republican states eight of the top 10
murder States you're not going to say
that your home city of San Francisco is
in good shape uh I'm saying that crime's
a real issue but I find the hypocrisy
the unwillingness to be honest with the
American people and the unwillingness to
take responsibility Ron DeSantis take
responsibility for his own crime rates
in his own major cities I find that
curious not surprising and I offer that
as a point of contrast and consideration
that's all oh and of course Dana
banshiers
um just a [__] [__] you're not
really saying that uh San Francisco
doesn't have a crime problem that's not
what he said at all
when did he say that did he say that I
didn't hear him say that I thought he
said something else now they really the
media hates when Gavin Newsom brings the
facts okay really [__] hates it now
I'm here to tell you that Gavin Newsom
is probably going to be a big contender
in 2028
for the presidential nomination
but you know one thing that Gavin Newsom
is going to be
in this next 18 months
he's going to be one of the best [__]
Biden supporters out there the best
Biden weapons out there
and he comes at him with [__] facts
every single time and he destroys Gavin
Newsom if I can give him a nickname is
the LIE Destroyer oh my God he destroys
lies watch this some of this by the way
but he also adopted me he made us he
made the country energy Independent by
the way more than seven to five years we
are more energy dependent today look
that up it's a fact and if you no one
else no it's just facts
encourage the people watching people
watch nine four quads Google 9.5 look at
all
uh-oh uh oh did you see what Gavin
Newsom did there
that that hardly anyone else has the
balls to do
not only did he look at Sean Hannity and
tell Sean handy that he's full of
[__] [__] because Sean Hannity is
full of [__] [__] he looked at the
camera
he looked at the camera and told the
people at home watching Google this
thing and Sean Hannity's like [__] jet
shut him up shut him up Google this one
thing if you Google this one thing you
will [__] find the truth not listen
to this [__] chucklehead in this
[__] Network listen to where he keeps
going he keeps going this is how you
[__] combat these these Liars
independent today under Biden Pence
doesn't know that your audience doesn't
know that more domestic oil production
than any time in history we're on Pace
this year that's a fact you guys keep
making that up no we don't make it up
you're making it up we're energy
independent and now with our energy
Independence no we're not energy experts
we are not Sean this is going to be so
much fun when this gets passed away
tomorrow and War go there look at all
nine four quads that's the margins the
highest margin of net energy export in
America's history under the Biden
Administration I did have a little fun
and for once you actually got back for
PolitiFact tomorrow it's gonna be some
fun political fact why don't you go to
the great I want you to go to the
Washington Post fact check
[Music]
oh my God Sean Hannity you look like a
fool
you look like a [__] fool what an
idiot
why would you why would you why would
anyone
who thinks they're gonna challenge Gavin
Newsom live on a [__] TV screen why
would they have him on their show what
in the [__] is wrong with you you think
Gavin Newsom isn't gonna know facts
he's the LIE Destroyer for crying out
loud
not only is he the LIE Destroyer he
knows narrative almost better than
anyone in the country he's one of the
best Democrats at narrative I don't know
if you noticed that either the guy never
lets down never lets down his guard for
narrative just keeps going that's one
thing that is gonna a catapult Gavin
Newsom to be one of the star contenders
in 2028 for the nomination of the
Democratic president of the United
States rather he will be or not I don't
know all right that's a long ways off
but I will tell you right now he's going
to be one of the ones and we need Gavin
Newsom in the fight
to show the country how [__] big of a
lie that Trump's support is that's a big
[__] lie that that the majority of
the country or half the country supports
Trump [__] no they don't the half
the country is sick and tired of that
[__] so much so that they would
just like him to go away half the
country I bet 50 of the country right
now in this moment right now if everyone
took a [__] Vote or a poll would say
if if Donald Trump just went away for
the rest of our lives just went away we
didn't have to hear from him we didn't
have to [__] talk about him we didn't
have to think about him we'd let him off
on all 91 [__] charges just go the
[__] away just go the [__] away and
leave us the [__] alone
leave our country the [__] alone and
we'll let you live your life somewhere
and we'll drop the 91 charges I bet
everyone I bet 50 percent of the country
would take that [__] vote
I bet they would but there's no one
there's no one that can compete with
Gavin Newsom on messaging oh besides
besides this guy
uh King Jeffries the minority leader in
the House of Representatives
and if we have anything to say about it
and if we have anything to do about it
folks Hakeem Jeffries is going to be the
next speaker of the house as you know
Hakeem Jeffries beat Kevin McCarthy time
and time and time again
for the speaker vote earlier on in the
year just the problem was he didn't have
enough votes to become speaker but he
always had yeah the majority of votes
the majority of the time but let's
listen to Hakeem Jeffries and how good
he is at narrative and messaging
maybe and right now
Republican extremism is rearing its ugly
head
there we go they are wasting time
and taxpayer dollars in an illegitimate
impeachment inquiry
when we're
about 48 hours away
or so from
an extreme Mega Republican government
shutdown
and this is what they're focused on
in illegitimate impeachment inquiry
as opposed to doing the business of the
American people which is quite simple
live up to the agreement that you
negotiated
and right now and there's the king
Jeffries always on point always on
message he's extreme Mega Republicans
extreme Mega Republicans extreme Mega
Republicans he never lets it down
I mean he doesn't go as far as I go you
know I call him Republican Nazis
but you know not a lot of people are
going to go as far as I'm gonna go hey
you know I understand that to some
degree
even even even glitchy Mitchy
knows how ridiculous the extreme Mega
Republicans are as I call them the
Republican Nazis let's see if glitch
McConnell here can work really hard I
Works nowadays not
to pause too long
shut it down the government
it's not like pressing pause
it's not an interlude
that lets us pick up
where we left off
you can actively harmful proposition
instead of producing any meaningful
policy outcomes
it would actually take the important
progress being made on a number of key
issues
and drag it backwards
oh he's working really hard not to
glitch isn't he
oh [__] not to have that mini stroke
right in the middle of him bashing the
Republicans for shutting down the
government you know what's funny about
this [__] you know what's funny about
this you know it's it's [__] Rich
about Mitch McConnell coming out through
the floor and excoriating Republicans
for shutting down the government this is
the same [__] this is the same
[__] that said the Republicans
number one agenda agenda item
in 2006 their number one agenda item was
to make sure that Barack Obama was not a
second term president
and this [__] is is knocking on
Republicans for shutting down the
government give me a [__] give me a
break
this [__] has shut down the
government himself
come on man come on what do you who the
[__] are you trying to fool
glitch McConnell here just knows that he
has to be against the extremist in his
party no now even though he created the
space for them to be in it
who do you think other than Mitch
McConnell has created the ability for
extremists to take over the House of
Representatives and take over Senate
seats
who do you think it was
Mitch McConnell believed that if they
just elected Donald Trump they could
control that buffoon
that's what he believed he believed that
they could use the presidential pin at
the behest of the dummy Donald Trump
and they believed they could control him
but they did not understand what a
[__] Maniac actually looks like and
does they had no clue
because they're only interested in their
own power all the time every time period
and full stop
never thinking about the American people
never thinking about the institution of
democracy never thinking about the
institution of the senate or congress or
the office of President the office of
the presidency
they don't give a [__] about any of that
never ham never will don't let Mitch
McConnell fool you here when he's
telling that the Republicans did not
shut down the government
Mitch McConnell only understands one
thing at this point is that he needs to
stop Donald Trump
and it it is telling it is telling that
just years ago he thought his number one
goal in the whole world was to stop the
black man from being president again
because we just couldn't have a black
man as president oh my God he's got to
be a one-ter that's our number one
agenda item
that's their number one agenda item is
to make sure Barack Obama is only a
one-term you remember that [__] right
I'm old enough to remember that
glitchy Mitchy [__] out of here with
this nonsense that you're
now you've all of a sudden grown a spine
come on Turtles don't have spines do
they
I don't know do turtles have spines I
have no idea I fell I was asleep in in
biology if you want to know the honest
truth I was completely [__] asleep
boy so I think uh
Gabe Sanchez is going to join us we
might as well do some promotion here as
we come to a uh the bottom of the hour
you guys know that Gabe Sanchez does a
live show directly after this show on
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday and by my
count I know I know I know Jason Smith
uh of Missouri doesn't know how
calendars work and he doesn't know how
to set 2017 works but today is Thursday
September 28th and Gabe Sanchez is gonna
have a live hour right after this hour
on YouTube and twitch it is called what
was that live with Gabe Sanchez
so don't go anywhere if you're on
YouTube and twitch and go ahead and hit
the Subscribe button if you're here on
YouTube don't forget to do that also I
don't know we we posted yesterday so I'm
doing this new thing with the audio did
you guys know we have the audio version
of the show too
so I used to just put the whole audio
version as one piece but I decided that
I would do it in two different parts now
on the audio version on Apple Spotify
Google wherever you download the podcast
and audio version there's thousands of
people who download the audio version
every single day but I I did it to in
two parts we're gonna start doing it in
two parts so the first 30 minutes that
rant that I do every day that's gonna be
part one and then everything after
that's gonna be part two so if you're
out there wondering why why it's in part
one and part two now it's because we're
deciding to do that so that way you can
listen to the rant alone or you can
listen to the entire thing by listening
to part one and part two so you know
that those are the two different parts
of the show so make sure to go download
the audio version on Apple Spotify
Google download both parts listen to
both parts if you want to re-listen to
the the rant that's part one of the
podcast every single day so you'll see
it changing over there also I want to
remind you you if you have your Amazon
Prime account tied to your Twitch
account that you don't forget to go
renew that and resubscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast we had hippie chat
hippies back
uh just about an hour ago
re-subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast with their Prime account on
Twitch now if you want to know how to do
that if you want to know how to tie your
Twitch account to your Prime account so
that you can give us that one free
subscription that you get with your
Amazon Prime account it makes it
commercial free on Twitch and it gives
us a couple bucks of Amazon's money so
we get a couple bucks of Jess bezos's
money and it doesn't cost you a single
extra dime it's a free way to support
the show monetarily without you spending
any extra money if you have an Amazon
Prime account go to thetonymichaels.com
scan down the directions are right there
on how to link your Amazon account and
your Twitch account and you go in each
month and resubscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast with your Prime account
and we get that free subscription every
single month and I appreciate all your
guys's support as always we're going to
take a quick break when we come back
we'll be more clips of rake steppers
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show all there is
more and more Clips
coming out
of the pretend impeachment inquiry the
Sham hearing that the rake steppers in
the house
have decided that it's a good idea to
continue to dig their political grave
and the Democrats are not going to take
the shovel out of their hands in fact
they're going to encourage more of it
here is AOC giving some of that
encouragement let's listen the
Republican majority has called in three
witnesses to advance their case
Mr Turley I have a simple question for
you in your testimony today are you
presenting any first-hand witness
account of crimes committed by the
president of the United States no I'm
not no you are not Miss O'Connor you are
the second uh Republican witness here
today have you in your testimony
presented any first-hand witness account
of crimes committed by by the presidents
of the United States I have not thank
you now Mr tubinski as the third and
final Republican witness in this hearing
have you in your testimony presented any
first-hand witness account of crimes
committed by the presidents of the
United States I have not and the
Republican majority has called in three
witness oops oh oops
oh so you're so you're actually not
Material Witnesses is that is that what
you're saying you're not Material
Witnesses
oh my God oh my God I gotta get to a
venmo chant that was sent yesterday it
was sent by Rico and Discord he said he
did give his Executives condos that's
why the CFO is in jail and he lied on
his taxes about that you know this kind
of goes with the clip that we just had
you know what I mean because like there
is evidence of all this stuff that Rico
is talking about here he did give his
executive condos and his CFO did Alan
Weisler did go to jail
and he lied about all of that that's why
there's felony charges in the Manhattan
DA's office about his fraud and that's
the reason why he lost his business
yesterday well some [__] some [__]
so thank you Rico and for the venmo chat
if you guys want to get in on the venmo
chat just go to the Tony michaels.com
it's the Tony michaels.com the venmo
Super Chat link is there if you guys
want to get a message up on the screen
just hit me up there I'll bring it up
Rico is at the very end of the show and
I missed it yesterday because we were
talking about Trump and I showed the
clip of trump bashing unions and bashing
pay and bashing workers like oh I'm not
paying workers a goddamn dime I'm the
one that gets all the money not the
workers not the people who do the actual
[__] work to make me profit I'm not
going to give them any money at all
foreign
yesterday of Donald Trump I don't know
why the media didn't play that clip over
and over let's see if we can find some
more Clips uh here we go now let's see
if we can here's more Jonathan Turley
probably stepping on a rake let's listen
for a house inquiry I've always said
that I thought it was a best practice
and your recommendation to him today I
mean he's listening I'm sure his staff
are would be bring that vote to the
house floor I always think it's a good
idea to bring it to the house and it
would be your testimony based on what
you've said that if that vote failed
that should have some real consideration
in whether we go forward with this I
mean let's put members on the road
because my my view is they don't have
the votes I think it's going to be a
very lopsided vote against it and that's
why they're not bringing it to the floor
yeah I can't speak to that let me ask
you this you also said that I do not
believe that the cover current evidence
would support articles of impeachment
and I want to be careful because you've
said it you think it supports an inquiry
but not the articles of impeachment
themselves I want to be precise in what
you've said can you explain uh to the
committee and the country why you
believe that the current evidence does
not support the articles of impeachment
today well at the moment these are
allegations and there are there is some
credible evidence there that is the
basis of the allegations but I
understand that and I'm not questioning
that I'm questioning what you don't
think today if you were going to vote if
this was the case you would vote no
correct on this evidence certainly
because okay and my question is if
someone said to you okay Mr Turley why
are you voting not to impeach President
Biden based on this evidence where do
you think the evidence is lacking where
where does it not rise to to the level
where you think uh it needs to be what
are the places that you think is is
missing well I said in my testimony that
the key here that the committee has to
drill down on is whether they can
establish a linkage with the influence
peddling which is a form of corruption
and the president whether he had
knowledge whether he participated
whether he encouraged it we simply don't
know and we don't even know if this was
an illusion or not but you can't find
the answers to that I mean the the back
end of these Financial transactions
which I have read is where the committee
is going May shed light on that but
without that type of Nexus then no I I
don't and currently it's your testimony
that that Nexus has not been established
correct no I think that's purpose of the
inquiry yes that's correct
would you agree with uh have you read
Ken buckshop Ed in the Washington Post
where he basically was one of the
uh-oh more Jonathan Turley being
questioned harder about how no there is
no evidence
of the house I've always said that and
of course he does the dance where the
like inquiry and articles inquiry and
articles but what the the actual the
problem here is that that Jonathan
Turley has it and that he's not really
being forthright about is that an
impeachment inquiry
typically historically like the last one
two three four of them go to a vote on
the floor this one has not gone to a
vote on the floor uh it just hasn't done
that so here here again is AOC some more
and they're playing this [__] on Fox
News folks this is Fox News Clips the
Fox News audience is seeing this [__]
so the Republicans are really stepping
on rakes not only are they stepping on
rakes but they're showing the entire
world including Their audience that
they're stepping on rakes so uh I want
to emphasize why that's important
earlier today one of our colleagues the
gentleman from Florida presented up on
this screen
something that looked appeared to be
a screenshot of a text message
containing or insinuating an explosive
allegation
that screenshot
of what appeared to be a text message
was a fabricated image
it was a fabricated image I don't know
where it came from I don't know if it
was the staff of the committee but it
was not the actual direct screenshot
from that phone and in fact I would like
to submit to
the committee the actual full context
from as from the Ziegler affidavit
number one exhibit 402 of the full text
of that exchange do I have permission
from the chair
importantly
what was brought out from from that
fabricated image excluded critical
context that changed the underlying
meaning and allegation that was
presented up on that screen by this
committee and by by members of this
committee now they are well within their
right to do that
because they are covered by the speech
and debate clause
this was not submitted by a material or
fact witness under oath
that was not submitted by material or
uh oh even more kinks in the armor of
the evidence really the the long and the
short of it here is the non-evidence
that exists against Joe badden
Japan
oh my God it gets worse and worse and
worse now let's see here's another clip
let's see what this one is I mean I
could just just play these all goddamn
day long to diminish Donald Trump's own
two impeachments his first impeachment
for trying to illegally bribe a foreign
government to help him with his campaign
and the second for a deadly Insurrection
in the halls of this Capital after he
asked his followers to tear through the
halls of Congress which they did with
zip ties looking to execute the former
vice president
and we know that Donald Trump has called
for this impeachment inquiry because we
have the direct evidence from his own
social you can see it right here he says
impeach the bum
and we also know that he's been directly
coordinating with members of this
committee as reported by the New York
Times right here a member of this
committee has been briefing Donald Trump
on this inquiry we also know that if
Donald Trump doesn't get his way he
wants his loyalists to shut down the
government how do we know that because
he posted it right here on his social
media
and his loyalists in this commit
committee who are doing his bidding for
him today we tweeted it
oh my God receipt after receipt after
receipt after receipt listen when this
impeachment thing came remember when
Kevin McCarthy came out in front of the
microphone and he was like yeah we're
gonna we're gonna have one of them
impeachment acquiries we're gonna do
that and the reason why I did it is
because Matt gatz was going to go to the
floor and call for him to be removed do
you remember this this couple weeks ago
I did a show on it it was like the lead
up to the show I showed you the clip of
Kevin McCarthy coming out terrified
because Donald Trump told him you better
impeach or I'm going to have you removed
and Matt gatz is going to do it Matt
gatz still went to the floor and still
made that statement even though Kevin
McCarthy did this sham impeachment
inquiry which isn't a real impeachment
acquiry because no one's voted on it no
one
no one
no one and I told you then that day that
morning you can go [__] find the clip
if you want I told you that morning when
Kevin McCarthy said that that he was
saying it at the direction of Donald
Trump
Donald Trump wants the government
shutdown he believes his own [__]
Donald Trump believes that if he shuts
down the government that they'll they'll
get rid of the prosecutions
because the government's the one running
the prosecutions my friend so if we shut
those down then I won't be prosecuted
he's full of [__]
Donald Trump believes that if Joe Biden
is impeached it's going to help him win
and the reason why is what I said before
well Donald Trump's a criminal but so is
Joe Biden so I'll vote for Donald Trump
but the receipts are there it's all
there it's all shown it's all clear it's
not [__] rocket surgery it's really
easy these [__] boneheads are
predictably unpredictable and boy is she
doing a good job of bringing the
receipts so let's watch more of the
receipts
the government and impeach is because
this is the last chance to defund these
political prosecutions against me
so folks this is not a serious inquiry
this is not a serious hearing in fact
the witnesses here don't even believe
there's enough evidence to impeach their
own members don't even believe there's a
much is enough evidence to impeach in
fact they refuse to hold a vote on the
floor of the House of Representatives
because they didn't have enough
Republican members who would vote for it
to demand the reason why they don't have
enough Republican members to vote for it
is because there's Republican members
who are in Joe Biden districts and they
will lose those districts
they will lose the House of
Representatives if they vote on
impeachment on the floor star gown 46
here on Twitch says rocket surgery again
yeah it's rocket surgery right and I
know it is rocket surgery yeah I think
it's Ruckus
everyone's questioning my dad jokes
I got some good dad jokes I'm a dad you
know what are you gonna do I'm trying my
best up here I'm trying my best we got
about 10 minutes left here in the show
at the top of the hour Gabe and Sanchez
we will go to his live one hour show
what was that line with game Gabe
Sanchez
I'm gonna see if he's gonna join us here
he's going to join us to to prep you for
what he's going to talk about I I could
only Wonder uh what Gabe Sanchez is
going to prep you or is going to talk to
you about oh hey look here look here
here's some more hearing oh boy let's
let's see let's
in a clip after clip after clip let's
see it Republicans are tripping over
themselves trying to distract and
deflect the American people with this
shameful show I thought she was gonna
say [__] didn't you this shameful [__]
shoe oh man she should have said it
right
come on representative Brown come on say
[__] show it is definitely a [__] show
the Department of Justice and the FBI
under former president Trump spent five
five long years looking into these
Republican conspiracy theories and
debunked them
repeatedly
so now in a vain attempt to deflect from
the chaos and confusion they are causing
House Republicans want to dig them up
yet again
Republican oh
boy it's listen this is all of their own
doing this is all of their own rake
stepping this is all what they wanted
they wanted this they wanted it so
desperately because Donald Trump is
directing them to do this folks the
reason why this seems so [__]
ridiculous
the reason why it seems so [__]
ridiculous is because they're doing all
this
all this theater all this [__] for
one [__] now I want to give you
a little bit of context here and that's
the reason why is because this is
authoritarianism on display
that's what this is
this is all to protect their dear leader
they're dictator their King
they're Jesus they're Republican Jesus
here
is all of this all of this government
weaponization of government all of it
non-government government that they're
doing is for under the direction of one
person and one person only and that
is Donald Jessica Trump the person who
wants to be dictator and King of the
United States of stupidity
and that's why we can't function because
they're trying to be authoritarians and
they're doing a damn good job at it if
you want to know the honest truth
they're doing a damn good job at being
authoritarians in the House of
Representatives
I mean it's disgusting it's hilarious
it's laughable
it's ridiculous
but we have to keep pointing it out
we have to keep showing people why it is
so important to elect people who are
serious about our government who are
serious about governing who are serious
about policy and most importantly are
serious about democracy
why we have to keep pointing it out
it's not going to get any better if we
don't
it will continue to get worse and worse
and worse and worse
now let's see
I don't really want to show a clip of
hmm
of Kevin McCarthy at this point let's
see here's another clip of the hearing
I'm sure this one is going to get crazy
let's watch Professor Turley in 2006 you
wrote an op-ed in the guardian entitled
quote stop persecuting polygamous
there you liken polygamous to quote
persecuted minorities and you said
polygamy is quote a practice with deep
and good faith religious meaning isn't
that what you said
I represented the Sister Wives uh family
in challenging a a polygamy prosecutor
the answer is yes you've been crusading
for legalizing polygamy for years in
fact in an op-ed
in the USA Today
you said that a Utah polygamist named
Tom Green who was also convicted of
pedophilia for raping his 13 year old
stepdaughter should not have been
charged with polygamy now Mr chairman
and I'm counting that's not can I
respond because it's not entirely
accurate I actually criticized him what
I was dealing with was the
constitutionality of what is called
morals legislation and I admit I'm
pretty libertarian was Tom Green
convicted of pedophilian rape government
the answer is yes Mr chairman
ooh Jonathan Turley
now you know why I was calling him a
scumbag earlier do you remember that
I don't know why Professor Turley I have
no eye idea why they think that Jonathan
Turley is a good witness at all like at
all
at all
okay let's see if we can find some more
crazy Clips here we go all right here's
a here's some more Hunter Biden stuff
and then we'll go to a Daniel Goldman
clip that 20. 20 companies
a lot of companies for an average
American like myself you know I got a
W-2 uh you know I filed my income taxes
my wife and I have simple
returns
but when it came to um
president
Trump how many companies did he have
anybody want to take a guess
I Miss O'Connor how many companies did
Mr Trump have
I have no idea the number but okay I
reclaimed myself thank you I reclaim my
time reclaim my time see you can't even
answer a simple question right he had
over five will the gentleman yield no I
will not no he also had over 500
companies over 500 companies
I looked at the tax returns why because
I was on the Ways and Means Committee
and I got to actually dig into it over
500 companies actually between 517 uh to
543 companies
and Republicans had no concern about
that when it was there were structure in
a way they were almost like a set of
Russian nesting dolls each one hiding
the existence and who controlled the
others but did the Republicans bring it
up no did they have any concerns no but
what happened last week or this week
let's take a guess
a judge said that uh president Trump
committed fraud business fraud foreign
inflating the value of his net worth and
his companies but when it comes to the
Republicans they have no problem with
that right they have no problem they
don't want to dig into that
when Trump controlled these 517
companies when it came to uh Hunter
Biden controlling 20 oh we see we see a
direct line to Joe Biden so that's what
the problem is is that they're they're
cherry picking
facts to connect it to Joe Biden and
when they don't have facts they make it
up let's do I mean that is republicanism
isn't it when they don't have facts they
just make this [__] up I mean why not
why not just make this [__] up wherever
you want however you want I mean you
know what if there's not a fact to back
up what we want we just make that [__]
up 100 full stop and we're going to
watch a clip here of Daniel Goldman uh
oh no no
let's see
let's see Gabe Sanchez is not going to
be joining us today but he will be doing
his show so take note he will be doing
his show here
um
so if Gabe is out there listening I've
got your show on on Mark it is already
loaded and ready to go but you know the
the actual okay here's
let's see
we're running out of time here and so
here's what we'll do we'll do more of
these clips tomorrow I promise we're
gonna be we're gonna be doing glitz
tomorrow tomorrow's bonehead of the week
it's Friday you know what that means
bonehead of the week you can vote
tonight for bonehead of the week go go
and make sure to follow us on YouTube if
you're on YouTube right now hit
subscribe you'll see the bonehead of the
week Poll for you to vote you decided
it's about another week and we will
break it down tomorrow in the second
hour you can also you can also vote on
Discord you'll be able to vote tonight
on Discord for bonehead of the week let
me throw that link in in the chat here
one last time you guys are going to want
to go join Discord and also speaking to
Discord tomorrow morning I do my
pre-show one hour in advance of the show
on Discord if you're a patreon member so
go join the Discord and also go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels or go to
the tonymichaels.com hit the patreon
link there find that twenty dollar tier
and you will be able to join me tomorrow
on Discord live you'll be able to talk
to me we have a producers meeting so we
all talk together we have a lot of great
times on Monday and Friday mornings for
the pre-show so if you're already a
patreon member you want to join us
get in on the Discord don't forget to go
to the producers corner on Discord I'll
see you there tomorrow early and I will
see you audience tomorrow on two hours
of the Tony Michaels podcast same time
same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass speaking